un point avec du beurre craag notre
correspondant inquiet quant à kiev
bonjour gilbert comment se passe tout
d'abord la contre offensive menée par
les forces d'ukrainiens autour de
karkhiv
je pense que c'est dans la région des
rare qu'yves qu'il y a le plus de combat
en ce moment sur le sol les forces
ukrainiennes ont réussi à repousser les
forces russes loin de la deuxième ville
ukrainienne aussi loin que karkhiv n'est
plus sous le feu de l'artillerie russe
des lignes de bus il a été annoncé ce
matin avons commencé à circuler à
nouveau des lignes qui avaient été
suspendus au début de l'invasion et puis
il y à un unité de la défense
territoriale de harkis l'ukrainienne qui
est parvenu à repousser les forces
russes de l'autre côté de la frontière
et à atteindre la frontière à un seul
endroit ils ont posté une vidéo où il
s'adresse au président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky en disant regardez
monsieur président nous sommes là juste
à côté de la poste frontière clermont
très fier de succès de cette contre
offensive et c'est vrai que c'est un
succès pour l'ukraine mais il ne faut
pas oublier que un gros une grande
partie de cette frontière dans la région
dach qui vais toujours contrôlée par la
russie les forces russes qui maintenant
veulent défendre des terres qui contrôle
un peu plus à l'est de harkis vivent les
ukrainien essaye maintenant d'avancer
vers l'est et d'attaquer les russes et
endommagé les lignes par lesquels les
russes fournissent leurs armes et plus
au sud à côté de la ville de votkinsk
donc c'est vraiment en ce moment là que
ça se joue les ukrainiens remportent des
succès mais la bataille pour la région
d'arrivée loin d'être terminée gulliver
bonjour on va partir un tout petit peu
plus à l'est de l'ukraine où on l
offensive russe dans le donbass en ce
moment
alors le dôme basse c'est officiellement
la priorité numéro un pour la russie le
donne pas je vous le rappelle est
constitué de deux régions
administratives louhansk et honnête si
on regarde la carte de la région de
lougansk ont fait presque toute la
région est aux mains des russes s'est
depuis 2014 qui contrôlait le tiers sud
est de la région de lougansk très
rapidement au début de l'invasion ils
ont pris la partie
nord-est agricole ou très peu peuplée il
y a seulement 10% de la région de
louhans ce qui est toujours aux mains
des ukrainiens c'est ce qu'a confirmé le
gouverneur de la région mais là il y a
trois des plus grandes villes de la
région notamment severodonezk mais ces
villes ont été bombardés par les russes
très substantiellement détruit 90 % de
la population est partie une analyste
militaire ukrainienne ressortissants de
la région d'ailleurs à qualifier et
chacune de ces villes severodonetsk
l'institut skds errobi gêné d'être un
mini marioupol mais pour le moment le
cren continue à contrôler et à ses
villas et les forces russes navy
n'arrive pas vraiment à avancer dans la
région de donetsk c'est la même histoire
dans le sens où depuis 2014 la russie
contrôlait la partie sud sud est de la
région les forces russes ont réussi à
prendre un peu des territoires dans le
nord de la région mais encore des
grandes villes dans la région de donetsk
comme cela viendra où cramatte offre
reste absolument fermement sous contrôle
ukrainienne et les avancées des forces
russes ne sont pas du tout à la hauteur
des ambitions qu'ils affichaient il y a
quelques semaines gulliver crack depuis
kiev pour france24 merci beaucoup
gulliver tout autre sujet à présent